[Music]
all right i have a story of this woman
who
her ex was trying to get back at her
somehow
and he ate a hornet's nest the wait no
he didn't
though so what he ended up doing
was he posted these
posters joe's not here yet you have to
wait for him
he's in sneak peek he was trying to get
back and then so he's posting some [ __ ]
well i don't know i'm trying to get back
at her like trying to like make her life
miserable
that's what i said
teacher joe's interrupting the class
again and then
someone
[Laughter]
okay are we here yep i've been listening
they just think i don't
okay good i said you're interrupting the
class well it's not just that
it's just a distraction you gotta you
gotta acknowledge your actions have
consequences joe i'm sorry teacher i'm
listening
i want to get a good grade dude
tattletail geo
[Laughter]
i'm down for him to be in my group
project though
all right guys so what this ex did
is he posted these posters all over the
place
and it says chewbacca roar contest call
her number that's [ __ ] awesome leave
a voicemail with your best impersonation
winner announced via text 12 p.m august
13
2020. best impersonation receives a
hundred dollars
i would love that i would love that can
you guys do it
i literally
how do you do it see do you use your
tongue
right
that's all you're getting it's like too
high right you gotta bring it
is that her phone or chewbacca that
chewbacca's baby mama
i thought that was chewbacca after a
helium
anyway so this is the girl you're
playing
[Applause]
[Music]
chewbacca's sad
yeah i didn't realize it sounds a lot
more painful than i realized
yeah he's always like yelling at han
solo
he's just in pain all the time sounds
more like soybeans
so i did 41.
like who is this i keep thinking you're
saying like a food dish or something
guys there's a
10 hour video of star wars chewbacca
sounds and it has 380
000 views
so they're different sounds because it's
the same sound and that's
pretty crazy greatest hits baby
i don't even know who that is this is
too young for me i [ __ ] love blue
she's so cute that's how you know that
this is a different age
but people just know blue's clue i've
heard of it but then i didn't watch it
i don't know what that is well i know
cliff for the big red dog
what noise did he make he made it was a
it was like
page turn noise like oh you read them i
saw the card too
yeah yeah we didn't have well i didn't
have younger siblings
uh i always had nephews and stuff that
were like and was it on cable because i
don't have cable growing up you know
you guys are nick nickelodeon i did not
even for me
uh we have a big age gap so then it
started with teletubbies
and like [ __ ] like that i would watch
they would watch teletubbies they would
watch
um bananas and pajamas yeah i used to
watch that's my
first of all i had like reading rainbow
veggie tails
that's my [ __ ] my family wasn't catholic
so yeah in
a book or greetings rainbow explorer
they would watch that
at the same time as blue's clues yes it
was mr rogers it's on the same channel
you just leave it on it goes from like
door to door new door either oh you had
the leave it on option
oh you didn't have that i see i see
thank you [ __ ] we take for granted your
parents would just say you cannot watch
any more tv
they don't have that filipino it just it
just morphed
i'm really good at the vietnamese one
but i just wanted to give you the
feeling that the vietnamese one give me
give me what they would oh man what the
hell man you want to watch the tv
no it's it's more simply like turn it up
yeah you have to start every sentence
and ever
end every sentence oh man what the hell
man i man what the hell man turn it up
no man what the hell
right yeah oh that's the old man what
the hell that's pretty good
you know thank you thank you wow where
did anthony go
just kidding that's what blue's clue
anyway back to this story so jessica
is the one that kept receiving these
chewbacca roar
these chewbacca roar voicemails
why she look like a puritan or some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] look like she [ __ ]
jedediah's playing tricks on her dude
fine
you guys are cruel people why why she
does look like she's sitting on a stack
of hair
i'm still laughing about blue's clues
what i'm talking about you said you
didn't even find blue's clues liar
we're talking about jedidiah we can
focus here [ __ ] ezekiel the amish boy
is like
playing tricks dude so jessica from
australia
oh [ __ ] your whale oh she's a koala
mother of
three it's wala bite she's the mother of
three that's cool
australia pennsylvania i know
she so she was saying that at first she
thought it was hilarious she was like
this is actually a pretty [ __ ]
hilarious prank but the fact that people
keep
calling her at all hours of the day like
they're she'll be waking up by like
4am well i'm trying to win that hundred
dollars does she have a [ __ ] landline
you can just put this on her cell phone
and i was thinking the same i'm like put
it on do not disturb him
that's her fault at this point or
airplane mode
don't know how to use these phones
properly sorry i didn't mean to blame
you it really isn't your fault
yeah she's amish she's amish is she just
gonna go down and like
around and take down the signs so that's
the thing so
whenever she does answer the phone and
she and then she
don't answer the phone so then she
starts like laughing like okay let me
hear it or whatever like she'll play
around
she'll play with the person and then
she'll end up letting them know like
actually this is a prank like if you
if you see that poster can you please
pull it down for me and then like
hopefully no one else calls
that's the best response you can give
laugh it off and then that's exactly
she's not about it she's my opinion and
so she's just like
oh so the other thing that her ex did
which is so for it's a chewbacca thing
and also
he left his old car with like he took
off the tires no and blocked her in her
home
on the driveway that's [ __ ] uh that's
an [ __ ] he's just a straight-up
[ __ ] yeah but
she could call a tow company and get
that you gotta pay for that he does
it's his car yeah it gets impounded she
did contact the police and
it sounded like it was a back and forth
kind of situation because during
the interview she was like okay they
finally said they're gonna do something
about it so i don't know
the full details but it seems like she's
been dealing with this dude for a long
time i don't know about out there but
out here
like the tow truck company takes it
because the person who owns that car
has to deal with pain there's a license
plate unless they burn
or not no they blurted it out yeah but
wait
why is it on nine exclusive why was this
on the news
oh because this is how we found out
local news always has crazy [ __ ] like
this
news like i like so so did she did she
like yeah did she like call them be like
hey this chewbacca thing happened and
then like
honestly every time we talk about
stories
in this show i'm like who contacted i
bet you the family
there it is like why no because like i
feel i think on local news sometimes
they have like a segment of like weird
little shitty names and they're like oh
whenever you have if you have some weird
story just call in
so she's called in you wouldn't believe
what's happening to me right now my
ex-boyfriend
he's crazy yeah kind of like earlier
today we talked about the kid who took
his parents car on a joyride and then he
had to be outside
giving away his stuff for free as a
punishment it looked like
like they had like the news team had
just found out about that situation then
and there and they went out and they
filmed it because it was like
like live pretty much like he was giving
away his things
so i'm like is someone just like looking
for things to call them
that [ __ ] being on these is pretty funny
you know another way she could have got
rid of that car
have a sign that says free car but just
like no tires on it so like people
taking it out
would turn into an entire situation so
in case you guys were wondering if you
really want a free car
i'll take a i'll take i just got to put
wheels on that car
yeah you just put him yourself yeah
cause the wheels were actually off on
the side
oh my god back on
so you could have jacked the car up and
put the wheel on or at least
it gets a little funnier with the wheels
underneath it's like somewhere obviously
a little funnier
on this side of the car well in the
video because you've seen it there's a
screenshot of the interview
and so it's in the video it'd be a funny
prank too the guy could just write free
lawn free gate free tree and just go in
there because they're taking off yeah
they put them all over the house
oh dear everything's free at this house
somebody comes and takes the tree
yeah those are very resourceful
neighbors you shoulda
trees aren't cheap trees aren't
cheap man they're not treats no trees
are very expensive
oh yeah i was gonna tell you guys if you
guys were curious about the
the backstory three prizes yes that's
the drama
so they were about a tree market right
now they were together for three years
and after jessica logged on to her ex's
facebook account
she found messages that he sent to other
women and that's why she broke up with
him
why is he angry then maybe he was like
how dare you invade my privacy how dare
you catch me
maybe he's like i have the right to talk
to my cousin and then she's like you
shouldn't be flirting with your cousin
though
yeah that's the reason why they broke up
and apparently he's very immature
because she says
i thought when we first met he was
mature but
it just goes to show having a job
doesn't mean you're mature so i guess
that to her
him having a job i think all guys are
immature
i'd rather have um an ex that does this
and eats a hornet's nest and tries to
[ __ ] do some crazy [ __ ]
oh i don't know they both they both are
pretty crazy
well the x eating the hornet's nest is
yes
wow that guy i feel like that's the kind
of guy that will come over and bite your
dog's nuts
to prove a point right and then this guy
yeah he'd grab your dog and bite his
nuts off stop
moving god damn it i picture like a
french
french bulldog oh yeah and i pictured a
great
dane oh [ __ ] yeah and i saw the guy get
onto all fours
and bite him from the back
so the tail is wagging on the forehead
he's gonna have to lie on his back
yeah it's like positioned better i love
everyone's imagination
[Music]
you